on prend maintenant la direction de
saint-pétersbourg pour l'ouverture du
forum économique annuel
[Musique]
plusieurs milliers d'entrepreneurs et de
responsables politiques sont réunis pour
dessiner le monde économique post co
vide elle pour en parler nous retrouvons
jean marc sylvestre notre envoyé spécial
à saint pétersbourg bonjour jean marc
sylvestre merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors quel est le programme de la
journée les moments forts auxquels on
peut s'attendre pour ce forum
à bien écouter le premier moment fort
consiste dans l'inauguration de ce forum
qui a lieu d'ailleurs à ce moment même
où je vous parle par le forum est
inaugurée introduit par un discours du
gouverneur de saint pétersbourg
alexandre daigle off
il sera suivi d'un certain nombre de
participants qui sont à éviter et
notamment le président de la banque
mondiale met au programme officiel fixé
par les autorités russes
eh bien vous avez beaucoup de
discussions beaucoup d'interventions
concernant d'abord les conditions
économiques de l'après goût vide dans la
mesure où le co vide a changé quand même
beaucoup de choses à la fois dans les
rapports de force internationaux mais
également dans les modes de vie et dans
les façons de travailler
ensuite il y à un certain nombre de
considérations qui ont trait à
l'incidence sociale de ces modifications
et de ce développement
nouvellement économique avec deux focus
également un sur l'innovation
technologique le rôle du digital n'a
échappé à personne qui a une
accélération finalement de la
digitalisation dont seulement des
entreprises mais aussi de toutes les
économies
et puis un focus sur le problème de la
santé avec la question des médicaments
puis la question des bac ça vous savez
que la russie essaie aujourd'hui de
faire agréer son vaccin par l'europe qui
refusent pour l'instant où qu'ils se
noient dans un certain nombre d études
c'est un vaccin qui est aujourd'hui
vendu est appliquée dans un certain
nombre de pays du monde notamment dans
les pays émergents mais ça c'est pour le
programme officiel parce que ce forum
c'est un forum de business est un forum
d'affaires
alors ici dans les halls et bien
énormément de ce temple de la part
d'entreprises qui sont venus du monde
entier pour essayer finalement de
discuter business de faire des affaires
depuis quelque part et du développement
à la fois avec les russes mais pas
seulement avec aussi d'autres
concurrents ou d'autres partenaires du
monde entier
c'est l'objet principal de ce forum de
saint-pétersbourg qui permet si vous
voulez à la russie de montrer que
finalement après lé qu'ovide il faut se
remettre au travail pour une nouvelle
ère une nouvelle ère de développement
alors justement là ce forum et en
présentiel 1 cette année les dernières
il n'a pas pu se passer à cause de la
pandémie ce que la russie montre tel que
les échanges économiques restent en
bonne santé malgré la pandémie
écoutez malgré la pandémie malgré aussi
j'ajouterai le contexte politique la
russie veut montrer effectivement des
échanges économiques sont continue
d'être dynamique il faut les dynamiser
on a du retard à rattraper parce qu'
évidemment pendant l'année 2020 eh bien
on a vécu un peu entre parenthèses
mais l'objectif des autorités russes est
évidemment de favoriser ces échanges
alors quand je dis les autorités russes
je ne parle pas que des autorités
officielles russes je parle des chefs
d'entreprises russes qui sont là sur la
même longueur d'onde que leurs collègues
occidentaux
la politique c'est une chose l'économie
c'en est une autre
et ici on doit faire principalement de
l'économie même si le contexte politique
est sous jacent avec notamment la
question des sanctions et puis la
question des menaces de sanctions qui
finalement est ce à tout le monde en est
d'accord y compris que ce soit les
européens que ce soit les russes mais
aussi que je serai les américains ce qui
est un peu paradoxale les américains qui
l'a sont une délégation très importante
très nombreuses y occupe beaucoup de
place ici avec leur entreprise donc
économique d'abord politique ensuite on
va essayer d'être prudent sur la sur la
politique et de calmer le jeu
c'est l'objectif de tout le monde
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre en
direct de saint pée tard